if we'd have gone back a couple of
decades and said you know what are we
going to spend our time debating in the
world's most advanced democracies in
Britain and America
um you know we might have thought 20
years ago well gosh it was since we've
got the internet and accessed all this
knowledge and the opportunity to
exchange ideas we might solve all sorts
of things instead you know we're
discussing things like what's a woman
and uh when was America founded so
actually we've become stupider and um
I've heard anyway I didn't blame people
like Hannah Jones and her fellow
fabulous and and I wish they wouldn't
hold everyone back